tout est ce que vous êtes déjà tombé sur
des gens un peu barre comme ça qu'ils
attendent le dernier moment pour
déranger pas ma carte non j'ai pas tout
on sent les lie
mais les types qu'ils qui tape un peu
sur l'europe nous a déjà tombé sur un
homme
radin alors alors moi d'appeler naïma
non franchement c'est le tibet s'est
marré teaser mais je le sais mais qu'ils
arrêtent et je vais pas citer des noms
mais je le sais ben laden je connais
tous vos claviers
sans citer non dit la vérité je le sais
personne chez prada persil maritime et
non mais moi si les radins je me casse
bon bah voilà vous êtes classé en
deuxième et sans doute s'était cassé
alors je ne supporte pas soit on dit dès
le départ
écoute voilà je suis un peu ric rac et
il n'y a aucun problème assuré le type
qui fait semblant de fourier son veston
assumer en cherchant sa carte
touristique est déjà si vous sortez avec
l'ingestion du corps
bonjour aux candidats ils mangeront
valérie attendent je vais donc fouiller
leur veste aussi je n'ai pas quel que ce
soit le canard est il qu'on rajoute à la
radinerie hypocrisie le moindre lacet
agir a dit non pas d'un nom et en plus
pour moi radin c'est c'est la suite d'un
comportement par exemple il pourra pas
bien manger pourra pas bien vous
embrasser pour aller à bien vous aimez
il pourra pas bien vous caresser donc en
fait c'est tout va tout va avec la
radinerie monte et qui a beaucoup choqué
personne
c'est d'une séance agitée qu'à vienne
d'une sas et d'une sensualité sociale
kenny oui c'est vrai je pense que j'ai
raison c'est un état d'esprit ça une
mentalité dotera d'un mois par an que
j'ai un super pote
j'étais parti manger avec lui et une
copine qu'il avait une petite amie qu'il
avait depuis la veille et puis à la fin
du repas baila pays il a offert à elle
et puis moi j'ai sorti ma caravane
ménager ceux qui lisent ce qu'ils
s'équipent ne peux pas dire si elle a
envie de le dire mais c'était il ya très
longtemps on n'était pas faucher nancy
lille n'est pas fâché non est toujours
un pote à vous oui d'accord pour battre
voila voila je me sens un peu sur
raymond est ce que toi tu es tu as sorti
aussi ou bien avec une fille qui te paye
est ou non en bon non
jamais arrivé mais après ton histoire ça
se trouve le gars il voulait
impressionner la fille pour dire je te
mets au dessus c'est kelly c'est ma
copine et pourquoi tu perds est pas toi
ton repasse pas être anna on a compris
c'était vraiment compris que j'étais
libre à toi de les remercier d'être
dénoncés voilà termine souvent avec
mathieu et les parades 1 mais quand il
peut ne pas payer la même taxe sera de
retour lundi d'ailleurs la sarthe romain
dit alors au restaurant on termine repas
il appelle le patron est dit on vous
doit quelque chose qui vient de manger
et bah oui bah oui mais non c'est pas
difficile quand vous quelque chose
et parfois c'est parfois la personne
annoncé pour moi et passer la rampe même
le reste orale dans ça me gêne à chaque
fois là mais il faut aider les
restaurateurs il faut payer un logement
ce moment est allé au restaurant il
adore ben oui alors attendez vous voulez
un beau témoignage il est là je confirme
pour mathieu on n'est pas obligé de se
coucher parler des hommes avec qui on
vient parce que je peux vous dire que
dans les médias à part vous et deux ou
trois autres dont faisait partie jean
lui fait dire ils ont tous des pinces à
sucre 1 ils ont tous dit fois votre
salaire est arrivé à la fin ils vous
disent tous vous avez droit c'est bon
d'être ensemble ils vous laissent
joyeusement payer ben alors les puristes
sont souvent les plus radins barre et
non la preuve
généreux mais vous êtes père général
dans le dans le passé participé au début
de l'année
une fois par an vrai mais pas par les
jets au fait comment non mais quand on
l'a fait le tournoi vous avez dit je
vous offre un verre après ça on va
manger ou être mangé c'est pour moi je
suis tout ça mais son coup de barre et 1
personne n'y a cru un instant vous
sortez jamais car c'est ça qui est
incroyable ou banier s'en sortir alors
je dis je n'ai jamais d'argent sont
moins 10 de cartes je vous jure que
c'est vrai et comment il avait pas du
tout confiance macron s'enflammer ça
carton plus bas les gens les gens nous
font confiance et vous verrez si vous
verrez beinheim rire et ma chérie je
verrai quand un jour 1
vous serez tellement honnête que les
gens vous laisseront partir sans payer
et je vois là vous le dit non mais non
on paye bien entendu il faut payer
l'addition au restaurant